how would jesse and i got connected and
one of the things we did
on the 2020 presidential race was we
treated andrew
as much as possible as a e-commerce
product which sounds
cold and heartless but we we didn't have
a big ad budget right we actually had no
budget and it was funny because i was
i would go to events and a lot of the
events we were doing were either there's
political reporters there or
donors or fundraisers who are like more
traditional um and they're like you guys
need to be doing more of
x they'd be like you need to be doing
more roundtable events on certain topics
and we would try those we'd try to do
events we'd sell tickets on them and no
one gave a crap
like there were so many traditional
things like uh yeah everybody says they
want that but no one wants it um
and what they did want was rallies those
weren't great
um they wanted um like
various donation conversions worked some
didn't some didn't but like a lot of
times that we had a progress bar where
people like felt like their donation was
moving the needle on something they
cared if it was just like
donate for this random politician it was
less exciting um
so i guess my point was it it's almost
like you end up building this brand
almost solely on the voices of the
customer
right like is that like you end up with
this product that you know is gonna sell
because it's
literally like evolved out of
popular demand and that's what we felt
do you guys feel that when you when you
do this
you did a much better job at it than i
ever have but yes uh that
that you know that i think that's
exactly how it works yeah
so we shop cursing was one it was a fun
one we're like all you know when the end
curses like
you gets a lot more clicks people like
it a lot more so maybe know
let's find a balance i think people are
just starting to see the power of all
this i mean you think about something
like amc
and i i will always be one course
international film two i will always be
one course away from a film studies
major
um so you know so i'm perf personally
rooting hard for movie theaters to
recover
but like you know this crazy feedback
loop of uh you know twitter latched onto
amc as a name
um amc actually completed a billion
dollar financing as a result
and now the odds that amc is you know
continues to exist as a go forward um
you know going concern is much higher
than it was previously and so like it's
um you know i there's you know people
always like to talk and
i get i came from the investment side i
get it you know the fundamentals of the
situation and
this and that but you know i think
you're seeing those feedback loops here
where actually like it can make it's you
know
um the digital stuff can sort of make
its own reality it's not just sort of
one one way communication of what's
going on so one of my concerns
here there's only a select number of
companies
and one of them in particular facebook
that you can actually advertise with
and do this and they um facebook as the
first mover and
realistically that the platform they
created is like
the first the best mover besides you
know my i guess our myspace and a few
others but once once the once one is
built it's very tough to replace it
because it becomes
the fabric of society and how we're all
connected
but like right now in
like political campaigns and causes
cannot use facebook to advertise
and they're toast like they literally
have no other option
to get into the internet of marketing
which is where all marketing is right
now essentially um
so thoughts on facebook's role here
and what that looks like is that
sustainable going forward have you
looked at found other effective options
to sell your products
outside of facebook i know you mentioned
a bunch but doesn't sound like they were
a key player melania start with you but
like what are your thoughts on
facebook's role here
yeah i mean you know where my mind went
while you were speaking is the ios
updates i don't know if that's something
that um you guys have talked about or
jesse's winners explain it i haven't
talked about the podcast
like the new like iphone updates iphone
apple is uh rolling out new
uh ios 14 a new update to your iphone
and that'll roll out throughout the
course of the year so it's not going to
be like a one and done bam immediate
thing
but in when you update when you get that
notification to update your phone
and you update it usually do it
overnight whatever um
when you're done updating there will now
be a pop-up that basically will say
something along the lines of
um do you want to opt in to allow
you know brands or companies or
advertisers to trace
your activities um that is a default
right now so
if you're if you have an iphone it's
like but unless you go to settings
out not opt-in correct currently right
now
you're you're in it and you have to go
find it buried in settings topped out
the new ios 14 is going to
opt everyone out and you have to click
to opt in
okay now i don't think a lot of people
are going to click to opt into that
right and
that is basically going to or has the
potential
to really destroy or at least severely
mess with
the facebook you know business platform
um
when you can't trace the customers i
mean we don't we don't just like send
swimsuit ads into the wild right like we
use facebook to target uh women first of
all women
because that's all the products we sell
who are likely to buy a swimsuit and
that is what
has kept our customer acquisition costs
low it's what
has enabled us to scale as a good
business and if those
acquisition costs go up because suddenly
we're targeting you i mean
like you can buy women's swimsuit if you
want but you're less likely
you said the term likely to buy a
swimsuit
that's not simple that's probably what
thousands of data points
that facebook right i mean that's why i
love facebook
i think the other thing you see
happening at the same time is
you know for a long time we've kind of
had the
top of funnel digital spend to ourselves
because the branded advertise the
traditional branded advertisers have
been content to hang out on tv
and i think you're seeing like you're
seeing the you know
the uh you know both what apple's doing
um california rolling out the c
the ccpa last year you're seeing those
things which are shifting you know the
ability to target ads and at the same
time you're seeing
tv inventory really start to crater to
the point where i like i mean like
um super bowl week and super bowl
weekend is usually not a big deal for
e-commerce advertisers like you
there's periods in the year where you're
where ad rates spike and you're sort of
you know kicked out you know
it's it's harder to spend efficiently in
the auction and then there's periods
where there aren't this was the first
year like super bowl weekend was awful
uh you know you could you could just
feel a lot of you know sort of more
traditional brand advertisers who are
used to stepping up their marketing
spend around the super bowl
um sort of let you know flex into the
facebook auction they went they put
their money in digital
yeah exactly they have to because what
they've been doing for years is they've
just been bidding up
that you know they've been burying their
heads in the sand and bidding up the
value of the tv impressions
um and you know and just not putting
much into digital
um and so you can see these two you know
honestly not in ways that are great for
me
but like you could see these two things
come together which is if on the one
hand
you know a lot of the targeting
capabilities of you know facebook and
other platforms are restricted
and on the other hand um the offline
inventory is finally just melting down
to the point that like
you know that traditional advertisers
are forced with their noses held to
spend more on digital
um you know that that these things just
you know become
um sort of traditional brand marketing
platforms which you know has
has all the privacy benefits that you
know that you you know that you'd
imagine but also ha but have the
you know the downside of like less
relevant ad impressions for consumers so
you know you just
seen tight ads the way that tv's offline
inventory
i'm assuming is cable tv ads or
broadcast the biggest ads or billboards
and not so online inventory would be
what we're talking about um like
facebook
google that sort of thing so on one hand
facebook existence
is very very good for smaller companies
like you yeah
and i think as a consumer the smaller
companies are amazing
because i know the brand i feel a brand
like i've we've used brands um
there's one called outer known that's
actually like a sponsor here for our
podcast that we love like there's a
bunch i i love these brands
um there's a company called grayson i
love that i think they make great
pullovers and they they're like they
were an e-commerce company and like
when like when you i got you actually
zero point do the surveys and tell them
like hey these pants are awesome they
like stretch a little bit funny
and the next round of pants like we're
better and like sweet
this is a good thing right and there's
people like you starting companies
creating jobs incredible yes we created
a lot of jobs in covit i'm sure ecom
companies created
way more than sort of wholesale historic
businesses
we're higher we're on a hiring spree yes
so facebook enables that
right um at the same time
the more of these little companies that
sprout up facebook's monopoly
gets bigger which is probably a net
negative
so like what i'm what are your thoughts
on that that's like so
it's like i think that's the big push
and pulling i think you're seeing it in
eve like
it's clear on the ad side i think that
the the one that's
that people will start paying attention
to is the payment side as well because
everybody you know everybody people get
how facebook and google
and you know to a lesser extent amazon
make money uh
the the thing that people miss is if
you're not those three companies and
your
business and your pitch to investors is
that you're making money around
e-commerce it's on payments so
whether that's shopify or stripe or
um paypal or square or whoever it is all
these players are
are saying that they're going to make
money on payments like big investors
aren't looking at
andy and saying this is my go-to they're
looking at a payment company that's
helping the andes and the hubble's of
the world
make money is that what you're saying
you can either be an ad platform for
brands or you can be a capital provider
for brands and like
most people you know and most of the
entities in the you know 50 billion plus
um you know weight class um in this
space or one or the other
um and the payment side gets you know if
you like what does
payments really mean payments really
means like lending um you know you
you're integrating you're providing a
credit card processor the way you really
make money off of that is you're getting
a cup you're getting the small
businesses or you know
independent brands um you know
transaction data and then you're
extending them loans um so like
this whole push-pull of like supporting
the little guy but also supporting the
giant you know
it's wild could you imagine more extreme
dynamic of this you have
on the one hand this is literally you
know this is literally the most
efficient system
ever created to extend you know small
loans and working capital to mom and pop
businesses whether they're digital or
offline or both
um and so it's great and you you know
you literally couldn't you know
replicate it on the other hand
you just have these behemoths that have
access to you know negative cost of
capital money
that are allowed to just you know you
know uh shove it down everyone's throat
all day
um so you know so yes i think these
these exact kind of you know put
push and pull of the you know the
platform and everyone else
um that's exactly the that's exactly the
awkward tension i feel like it's amelia
i'm still curious your thoughts i just
feel like it's a good
thing until facebook and apple get in a
turf war and then who's gonna pay the
price
andy i think right like what do you
think i mean it's funny because that you
know we're talking about
the future like this the theme here is
the future of buying the or the future
of shopping and
and i mean first of all it's just so
opaque but second of all like
i think in a lot of ways there's going
to be a reversion
i mean maybe this is an unpopular
opinion but a reversion back
to at least some something that what you
know
i feel basically where i come out on all
of this is that i feel very thankful
that andy started when it did i think
it's becoming a lot harder to start a
small business
these days for all the reasons we've
just described um
and that's unfortunate i think it should
be going the other way which
you know there should be more small
businesses because like you said they're
great i love supporting small businesses
i love that they pay attention to me i
love the value like everything we've
talked
about but i think it's really hard today
um i mean in some ways the barrier to
entry is lower than ever
there is capital going around i mean i
feel like i can email every day with
people asking to give andy money
great but like you have to spend it
efficiently you have to build a good
business you know and i think that
that's the part that's becoming
it's just tricky
[Music]
you